hey there today we are talking about
designing in After Effects
instead of Photoshop hey there and
welcome to the motion science video
podcast my name is Cameron and I just
want to say thanks for being here today
and watching this video and spending a
few minutes with me as I talk to you
about why I choose to design an After
Effects vs Photoshop now when I tell
people I design an After Effects /
Photoshop I'll get a lot of what what do
you mean like no way like that can't be
possible my god it's very possible right
I started designing in After Effects
probably around 2009 2010 when I was
freelancing I'd been freelancing for a
few years and what I found was that I
actually have three main reasons that I
design an After Effects vs. Photoshop
the first reason is its non-destructive
like Photoshop no Photoshop is getting
some functions to it that make it not so
destructive but the second reason is but
it's still not there in terms of After
Effects the second reason is plugins
there's a lot more plugins inside of
After Effects vs. Photoshop and plugins
that come with it as well as plugins
that are available to purchase for it
and the third reason is pretty simple I
don't have to move from Photoshop to
After Effects I'm already there okay so
let me talk about the three reasons in a
little bit more detail the first one is
non-destructive so what I found was in
especially back in oh 9 & 10 when I was
designing a Photoshop or I was still in
Photoshop of moving into After Effects I
found that I was constantly frustrated
because I would have to duplicate layers
inside a Photoshop to apply effects to
them to cut things out to you know just
do my my typical workflow I was
constantly having to create an original
file in Photoshop duplicating that file
naming it something different and then
doing an effect duplicating that maybe
applying another effect
or some type of painting to it so that I
always had originals a step back inside
a Photoshop if I needed to go back and
in a lot of times I would have to go
back right I had to go back for myself
if I was making a change a creative
change if my clients saw something that
they want to changed I had to go back
and make the change and I just found
that it was kind of it was really
frustrating to me okay
because Photoshop had so many
destructive features to it now don't get
me wrong I still use Photoshop for
certain tasks in designing those tasks
mainly have to do with if I have to do
very fine cut outs I still like to go to
Photoshop to do those with the pen tool
I'm all about the pen tool right and
that's just my old-school ways there are
some amazing ways to cut things out in
Photoshop now but I still and I will use
those those magic tools and things like
that but I still find myself using the
pen a lot so if it comes to cutting
things out with very fine detail I will
go back to photoshop export exports
those to after-effects also if I have to
do painting I will find myself in
Photoshop now I don't do a whole lot of
painting for the work that I personally
do or have done so that's not a huge
reason but anything other than that then
those two reasons I can think of off the
top of my head I'm gonna be an After
Effects now when I started designing in
After Effects in o9o 10 and 10 the
studio's I was working for the time were
actually surprised by it because what
would happen was I was designing a lot
of style frames for production teams and
if my designs were picked at that point
how the process kind of worked was if my
style frames were picked i had to
package up those photoshop files those
frames all of the assets and send them
off to the production team where they
would then take them tear em apart
bring him in after-effects and start
animating and make changes things like
that when I started packaging up After
Effects project files for my chosen
style frames
and send those off to these teams these
high-level motion houses they were
actually kind of surprised like wow this
is this is awesome like everything is
already lined up in after-effects it
saves us a whole lot of time versus
taking everything from Photoshop
bringing After Effects and recreating
things in after-effects so I was saving
these teams a lot of time also there was
jobs where I was the one who designed
and then it was animating so I saved
myself a ton of time because like for my
personal workflow especially back then I
was doing a whole lot of two and a half
D and 3d work inside of After Effects
and you know it I found it easier for
instead of having to mimic 3d separation
inside a Photoshop flat 3d separation
why not just go into After Effects set
up my scene set up my camera everything
is where I needed to be it's just a
single still frame and I'm saving myself
a whole lot of time that if it gets
chosen it's it's ready to animate it's
already prepped to go right and I also
found that I could create I had a lot
more possibilities on this is before
Photoshop had a 3d viewpoint viewport to
it and I'm not a Photoshop master by any
means and in fact I use it less and less
and less like I said so there's some new
features have been added to it since but
just the fact that I could take my
layers and layer things up inside After
Effects and add a camera and just get
the exact view that I wanted to see if
my design was I mean it was priceless
right it was saving me so much time on
top of that I found that when I use like
designed a lot of style frames I was
using a lot of plugins at the end to
really bring my work to life now that's
what I call the polish now before I was
designing in After Effects I was
layering everything up in Photoshop and
then I would send all these Photoshop
files to After Effects and then in After
Effects I'd apply like my glows or my
different effects and things like that
depending on what the project was and so
it's just it was again it was just extra
steps that weren't necessary so it's
like why can't I've always said that and
I think
people say this to it you know after
effects his Photoshop on steroids
because it is right it's just it's
Photoshop in its after-effects his
Photoshop in motion now Photoshop again
is adding features like they're adding
timelines now so you can start doing
simple animations inside of Photoshop I
was I would stick with After Effects i
person at the time but it just saves so
much time in After Effects plus it's
non-destructive which was my initial
point it's non-destructive so I can
apply effects to my layers I can easily
control alpha and track mats and
whatever the case may be for the
particular project I'm designing its
non-destructive I'm not creating
duplicate upon duplicate layers just to
try out effects to see if they work
right because it's non-destructive and
then the third point of I don't have to
move from Photoshop to After Effects I'm
already there and I've talked about this
so in terms of time saving time going
from design to animation you're already
there you're halfway there already so it
just it saves so much time
and you know After Effects has most of
the a lot of the same tools of Photoshop
has it doesn't have the painting tools
which is again why I moved to Photoshop
for painting but designing in After
Effects also made me just an overall
better motion designer so even if you
are not a designer
laying layering images and and
compositions together in After Effects
and just seeing how things work together
when I'm designing that's what helped
build this artistic eye that I developed
over time because any of you that know
me know you know like he know that I did
not go to art school I did I've never
taken an art class in my entire life
everything was was taught from trial and
error and from just getting in there and
doing it right the the first day I was
asked to design a style frame um I was
already a freelancer at this point and
the production company was in
pinched and they said can you design a
set of style frames for us it has for a
huge cellular company at the time and I
panicked
I don't like I've know you want me to
design something well obviously the
creative director for the company he
recognized that I had a creative eye
based on the animation work I had done
for them and he trusted me enough and I
was up front with him I said hey man
I've never designed I don't know if I
can do this and he you know he really
pushed me he's like I believe in you I
know you can do this and he actually
gave me that confidence to just try it
so I designed these style frames and you
know deliver them to the client they
were ecstatic they picked my designs to
go with great but like I said it's it's
layering up these elements inside of
After Effects and just getting this this
I for what works visually what does and
what looks good what colors work well
together what typefaces work you know
all these things together that's what
taught me to be a better motion designer
so I would suggest you don't have to do
this if you're a power user in Photoshop
stick with Photoshop I mean you can
design amazing style frames but if
you're a little bit timid with Photoshop
and you want to explore After Effects
even more get in there and design inside
of After Effects so just to plug one of
my curriculums that I teach it's called
style craft and stock craft I actually
teach you how to design inside of After
Effects so that's one of the main things
I teach so that's what I got for you
today I would love to hear from you in
the comments if you are designing an
After Effects what's your take on that
because I know more and more motion
designers are moving towards designing
an After Effects until next time I'm
Cameron and this is motion science see
ya
[Music]
you